two
off the rails the first off the rails of
the year
let's freaking go
the first time
i just reached too much
have an inappropriate relationship by
the fortune of natalie
[Music]
portman wow
a master class wow
a master class of kavanaugh
i tried actually done
[Music]
i have a big kevin update i'm gonna put
at the end of the show just because we
we've already talked about a lot so if
you care
basically he's trying to take down our
website again he followed the new
complaint against it but i'll talk about
that at the end
hi everybody and welcome to off the
rails it's 2022
[Applause]
the world is not anymore the same no no
no
2022
loves in the building love
lots of thirsting for you bro oh yeah
did you you come on don't act like you
didn't notice that no okay dude
i saw lots of comments like
wow so hand like
so handsome he's way more handsome than
i expected he looks great in person
mom
thank you guys i don't know i didn't see
any of that oh stop it everybody you saw
you guys saw that right definitely yeah
he saw it come on in love
put me between your legs
all right
whoa whoa whoa don't get too close do
you want to go between someone's legs no
i don't know about that
it's a love machine now what's wrong
with that
anyway today's
episode is sponsored by mint mobile
curology liquid iv and harry's we love
you guys thank you
uh straight off the bat we got an action
pack show we didn't get to everything
on monday so we're just going to kind of
pick up where we left off kind of still
catching up like
lots of dramas
vanilla ice teamed up with a q anon
wrapper okay
okay you haven't seen this yet okay
billboard top 100 mm-hmm
i didn't know vanilla ice was making his
big comeback with uh
forgiato blow
[Laughter]
jfk
and jfk is coming back to life the magic
bullet don't hit twice
that's pretty good thank you nice which
reach out to them forgive blow is
related to donald trump supposedly he's
not
he says that he's he's donald trump's
nephew is what he refers to himself
i think that's a meme he's like the neff
yeah exactly
mike uh
uh but let's man the joe rogan and
peterson stuff i actually really wanted
to talk about because that was huge news
over the
break
but at the top of the show here we've
got
a shout out to a
a very special ad we saw
who caught did somebody actually get
this on their like yeah well a friend of
mine did and he sent it to me he was
like you got to see this ad i just got
okay so this is the guy from like cha
american chopper or what is it yeah
i don't know if you guys have seen this
show but it's basically
it's like uh
any of those garage shows they would
like fix
west coast customs for for motorcycles
it looks like they just bought a cameo
from him
and
turned it into a freaking pool ad i
don't know why there's paypal
the whole thing is just a wild wild
thing bro but this is the ad that's
currently being run i'm an old school
guy i have work ethics and high
expectations so in the end result it
always is a beautiful bike it's kind of
like pool i play rock pool
um you know you got two guys going head
to head
and
the ultimate prize is the cash with the
motorcycle company ultimately you want
to
get to the end uh finish the bike and
quite the cash so they're similar in
that particular way keep on banging
those balls
keep on baking those balls
[ __ ]
pretty awesome
i love the layout
even he's not even convinced when he
says it it's kind of like pool
[Laughter]
i would like to see a whole compilation
of celebrity cameos trying to compare
whatever they do in life to a playing
pool for money
look hey my name is ethan klein i do a
podcast it's kind of like pool in this
end of the way like i do it and i earn
money from it and it's just like
clanking those balls
same kind of thing you know
i've played pool a few times in my life
you got two guys clinking balls going
head-to-head
ultimate the prize is the cash
it's cash guys
i do a podcast with a bunch of guys just
like when you play pool
it's basically all we do here it's like
a
bunch of cool guys smoking
clinking balls together nothing like
clanking a few balls together boys
amen so that's that
um
yeah straight off the bat i'm gonna just
go for some keemstar cringe
um in our last episode
we showed he was making fun of my dad
for thirst trapping on people on twitter
and we showed a bunch of tweets of
keemstar saying way worse cringy
weird crap
show me boobs boner boner boner alert
boner owner and so he tweeted out ethan
klein got so salty now by the way
tipster is one of keem's friends so this
is pretty epic keem i never make kim can
never make fun of my tweets again i'm
literally experiencing second-hand
embarrassment low
i mean shout out to the tip i'm gonna
like to click some balls with them
okay [ __ ]
keemstar says ethan kline got so salty i
memed his jordan peterson tweet that
he's literally reacting to fake
photoshop keemstar tweets what's wrong
with him it's getting so bad extreme
cringe he says follows up with
okay so i'm fit he's faking it
extreme cringe
follows up with maybe they're real
maybe the real maybe the real tweets but
altered
you proved it and then he uh erased the
tweets wait show one more time the my
favorite detail is the last thing he
says there
yeah so by the way they are real because
he erased this just so fyi yeah extreme
cringe oops uh yeah what i just said he
says what's up with the big black boxes
so
we censored all of the the handles of
the people he was tweeting [ __ ] like
boobs and boner at right that's a good
call and um
anybody i mean this dude's been on
twitter for a decade how do you
how do you not know that how do you not
know that those are user names well
there's a very simple uh explanation
that he's very dumb yes okay
um that pretty much explains
a lot of things he does
yeah he erased it which is just great i
mean what a loser
um also
just a little bit i forgot to mention
this
you know keemstar on christmas day i'm
sitting there with my family
um with having a beautiful time
um
keemstar is tweeting about me on
christmas day right christmas day
he has a daughter he has a he has a
he also another daughter's best friend
he's also happens to be there aka his
girlfriend
you know he's there with his family he
says nah self-proclaimed comedians that
don't do stand up aren't funny at all
prime example this guy hires four people
to sit in the background of his podcast
and fake laugh at everything he says
okay first of all
i like that now keemstar's gatekeeping
comedy like unless you stand up and
perform you he's you are not funny
okay
um
and guys do you i mean he says i i pay
you guys to laugh so i don't know if any
of y'all want to uh he must have never
seen ian
yeah i don't pay ian enough ian never
[ __ ] laughs at my jokes
maybe zach maybe zach has a couple
forced last but not least i laugh at
everything i find everything
entertaining yeah ian what do you what
do you have to say to that i mean your
ass is you're a tough crowd
yeah i don't know i think i'm keeping
you on your toes pretty fairly so you
know um
so but then someone else realized that
last year so this is december 25th last
year on christmas day
keemstar was tweeting about me again
and this was before his midlife crisis
so he was with his baby mama his baby
his family
i mean
i'm basically hitler his parents weren't
there for obvious reasons
but he was surrounded by family
where's your daddy even klein has had
the worst
where's your daddy
anyway uh he by the way you misspelled
me for someone who's obsessed with me he
really misspelled my name okay i before
he okay well i guess technically
ethan klein has had the worst year ever
he tweeted lost subs lost sponsors lost
respect gained weight now trisha paytas
is his sister-in-law
i legitimately feel sorry for him ethan
if you see this i hope you have a much
better 2021 well thank you
and i look forward to your next tweet
about me this christmas day
what do you think it means that he's
thinking and these were unprovoked kind
of tweets right like i mean it wasn't
like a tit for tat this is just a
straight up it's christmas day i'm
thinking about ethan i'm gonna tweet
about him yeah what do you think that
means
maybe he's jealous that you're you know
happy with your family enjoying
christmas
trying to get under your skin yeah
perhaps
you know what he's probably trying to
take his mind off that dog
yeah he ran over the one that he ran
over yeah yeah
you know and a few things about the one
from last year i love that one of them
has lost respect
that is so funny to me you lost respect
you lost subs you didn't lose subs um
but every drama channel likes to use
your old channel uh analytics which i
uploaded on in two years oh okay that's
what he's talking about yeah
i mean i don't remember i mean
yeah sis patricia peters sister-in-law i
mean that is a huge l i'll accept that
that part he's right did um
do i recall correctly that uh kavanaugh
was also tweeting about you on christmas
that was thanksgiving oh it was on
thanksgiving he was what did he we
talked about it on the show i guess yeah
i was confusing him you posted with uh
theodore and ela on thanksgiving and he
commented under it something stupid he
did yeah you know
he commented under a picture of my
family about thanksgiving yeah
what is wrong with these people dude too
much wine sorry i guess that's why yeah
exactly too much wine
yeah and by the way here's the upcoming
ad for poker chopper heroes clinking
balls extreme edition
[Laughter]
uh
so yeah shout out to keemstar who is
always wishing me a merry christmas
also
one last thing
keemstar related he loves to always
bring up that uh
this was tweeted out two or three days
ago this to him is the biggest dub ever
you watch this and tell me what you
think he says it's all making sense you
know i have mental illness problems too
like that never [ __ ] she doesn't seem to
really give any credence to that like i
have depression i'm medicated for that
[ __ ] 20 milligrams lux for every [ __ ]
day
my dick feels like a piece of wood
like i have no sensation in my penis
side effect and i'm fat by the way also
a side effect
you know
i have tourette's by the way something
that she continues to tokenize which
always makes me uncomfortable i always
ask her to stop doing that
insisting that everything i do is oh
that's tourists that's tourette's
i don't like it and i tell her that
every time and she keeps doing it so
like you know
[Music]
it's just not fair i guess this was
during the jordan peterson thing uh he
says it all makes sense now i guess that
i take
antidepressant medic medicine uh is a
huge dub for him
so
what do you i mean what do you really
say i this is the guy who is notorious
for saying mental illness is straight up
fake
and then he went on a apology tour being
like i've educated myself now i'm more
sensitive to these issues three sips of
beer
yeah famously said all you got to do is
take three sips of beer when you're
feeling depressed that's it
so as you can see this is a is a
changed man
just don't be bro these two no these
takes are so toxic that i literally i
feel like you can't even show them or
you'll get demonetized you'll get mature
rated
i'm going to read them because we're
going to get this certified ahead of
time but the drug companies invent all
illnesses so they can sell drugs to
morons social anxiety is one hundred
percent a fake invented illness so they
can sell you drugs and make millions
stop being weak remember this is what he
said to etica before he um
unlived himself he said stop being weak
society is literally going to die if you
keep this [ __ ] up
real talk if you suffer from panic
attacks and you're old enough to drink
the best way to stop a panic attack real
quick is to have a sip of beer you only
need like three sips
so
yeah i mean ethan if you're sad maybe
you should just stop being sad just stop
have you considered becoming an
alcoholic
right um i mean that is a medicine of
sorts when when
he goes dude antidepressants is invented
by drug companies
unlike
budweiser by the way
now that's how you treat mental illness
and having some beers with friends yeah
definitely always has great advice just
close your mouth
just
oh yeah that too
just close your mouth well because i'm
fat no no no that no you
when the whole thing with jake paul
happened oh [ __ ] and that was his uh
advice
well
anyway that's enough for that
what the hell is this political ad for
gary
uh
first campaign ad 37 seconds just like
me i hope this ad works to not only
destigmatize the use of marijuana isn't
this like isn't that hasn't that already
happened
this is a new ad huh this is uh this is
gentleman is running for the senate in
louisiana and this video was posted
yesterday and his uh caused quite a
on the interweb i hope this ad works not
only destigmatize the use of marijuana
but also force a new conversation that
creates a pathway to legalizing this
beneficial drug for those who were
arrested due to outdated
ideology well first of all he's right
people in jail for marijuana use are
is definitely a in my opinion a crime
against humanity practically i mean what
a waste of humanity
uh and just cruel
so but let's see you know every 37
seconds someone is arrested for
possession of marijuana since 2010 state
and local police have arrested an
estimated 7.3 million americans for
violating marijuana laws over half of
all drug arrests black people are four
times more likely to be arrested for
marijuana laws than white people states
waste 3.7 billion dollars enforcing
marijuana laws every year most of the
people police are arresting aren't
dealers but rather people with small
amounts of pot just like me i'm gary
chambers and i'm running for the u.s
senate and higher ed
that's a fire after 37
it's the criminal justice system itself
that's on trial here i mean
uh that's a great ad what are people
saying they like it generally it's been
received really well uh obviously there
are a lot of people that think that um
that uh
that drugs that still have that mindset
that drugs are horrible and ruined lives
including marijuana and so there's some
people that are upset about it but
i think the vast majority of people in
this country at this point are in
support of at least decriminalizing look
i don't know i'm not a i'm not a
marijuana user i don't like it i don't
use it i think the risks of marijuana
are frequently understated that being
said nobody should ever go to jail for
marijuana or any drug use in my opinion
ever so
i'm straight up
loving this ad
that's awesome
good for him toke it up baby
that's sick i was expecting some
goofball [ __ ]
uh where's he running louisiana let's
get this man in office gary chambers
junior we should donate
let's go baby
uh anyway how's everyone doing what we
got planned today we got we're gonna
feed love some
weird foods
today
so there was an idea of feeding him i
don't know if you heard but i guess taco
bell has gotten into the wing game
and i said oh yeah i heard that
apparently it did not go over well
because they have already pulled it from
the stores sam has been trying to get
them home i don't know well that's funny
because their last foray until
the chicken sandwich was a was a huge l
you know
you got to admire him for just getting
up and trying again i guess it's true
you know
sam i see salmon back there dude you
didn't find any wings
she says no
sucks bro yeah but but love was kind of
doing a victory lap on that mexican food
yeah
i did i had no issues with that at all
it was great yeah i was doing great like
like the night that
afterwards and yeah no problems no no
fecal issues nothing
uh
for the next challenge basically
well we got you so have you ever had
taco bell no okay that's exciting so we
got a bunch of weird taco bell items for
love to try we'll see how your
intestines fair against taco bell boy
what i'm most worried about is that i'm
just a generally picky eater i don't
love cheese i don't love tomatoes i
don't like cheese
no not not want to taste cheese but you
know i can eat pizza and stuff like when
it's mastered i don't mind it
i think what you're going to like taco
bell yeah i think so dude
that [ __ ] is engineered specifically for
people who are picky eaters
it's like made to be consumed
cool
him and cam share one bathroom so that's
gonna be the real challenge
later tonight one bathroom one god
pants
one love
yeah we'll see
dude i'm [ __ ] myself
dude i'm [ __ ] myself
shit's coming out down my leg
you guys want i think i already made a
whole video about this pokey drama but
the one thing basically pokey mane
friend of the show great great lady big
fan
she's a twitch streamer for those of you
who don't know her
she's really
a big streamer
this is her for those who are not
familiar there was a really interesting
development but i'll just give you the
basic rundown is that some dude was hate
rating her
pokeman gets way too much crap she's
she's a pretty girl
and people just don't like women what
can i say there's it's it's a gamer
culture there's a lot of n cells there's
a lot of freaking
betas
and they say well the only reason she's
successful is because guys fantasize
about being with her and it's pathetic
and people always target her it's what
happened with this knit with this one
guy
this guy dijon who by the way i'll say
to his credit has apologized and stuff
and seems to have made a sincere apology
i don't know if it's just because he was
it's kind of crazy he was suspended for
14 days and then they converted it to a
permanent ban
and all of it happened on his first day
on the platform right or the first day
of being a uh he had just been partnered
and everything yeah yeah that's got to
be that's a speed run right there it's a
banter speed run
for sure
but i i i'm not super familiar with
twitch like culture and rules but
apparently
sending people to another streamer's
chat just to be hateful is like big big
big noto instant instant band [ __ ] so i
mean the guy should have known better
love you familiar with twitch i mean
you know pretty obvious outcome right
right yeah they have that raid feature
where you just send your shot to their
shots oh so they don't want people
abusing that
yeah it's a weird feature to be honest
i don't know it just seems ripe for
abuse yeah dan pointed out that it's
like very that's inevitable that that's
what it can be used for so he used that
feature
yeah oh crazy
and he encouraged people to like spam in
her shot and
yeah even after he was banned he didn't
immediately apologize he kept going on
with it on different platforms
yeah i'm going to show that i want i do
want to show that something i saw is a
lot of people were saying just pointing
to transcripts of the chat
saying it's not that bad because
basically they were just spamming l plus
ratio in her chat right which when i saw
that without the context of the actual
video i was like
that doesn't i mean
that seems kind of goofy like that's not
that's not that hateful
those were cherry picked you know on
twitch those well that was the thing
then i saw the video of
him organizing it and what he was saying
about her and telling and and with that
context it suddenly became clear to me
it's like oh yeah he was trying to bully
her of course keemstar got involved and
all these like reactionary insults and
like the quartering got involved being
like what is misogyny they're saying
misogyny it's like dude it's obvious
misogyny women hating i'll i'll show you
but here i guess this is it uh
guys guys guys yeah this is how it
started can you turn it up a little bit
dan from on my side i can't hear it too
well yeah
oh thank you zach follow her follow her
follow her follow her right now y'all
follow her right now
follow her right now we're going to be
back y'all we will be back
oh
yeah you let me follow her
bro what the [ __ ]
guess who's a better gamer you are john
by the way she's minding her own
business i don't even know why he's
doing this
um
the reason he's saying follow her
is because i guess her mods turned on
like follow only mode so you need to
follow her
that's why screaming follower
dan there's a clip of him before this
where he's
there or is the bad part in this clip
yeah it's a necklace okay okay good
watching beat don't don't stand where am
i she sees it oh wait i gotta move her i
gotta move
why is he doing he knows he's going to
get banned
like this is obvious ban on twitch
he is new he he very well may have just
not known that this was a big no-no i
think i merely buy the best challenges
okay
who's gideon do you know who gideon is
bozo i can't believe you can just eat
whenever you want you're getting good
before the round starts funny right
that's so fine
i can't go too crazy because twitch
loves her so i'm not gonna say anything
mean i have a blind for you all they
push you not gonna apologize you did
that [ __ ] to yourself i'm fired should i
give sub so we can ratio her again y'all
yeah i think it's worth it
[ __ ] bruh i really don't want to give
her any money i really bro they turned
sub mode on so fast
they turn sub mode on so [ __ ] fast
these are confusing bro oh bro
that is so funny
and yes my area sucks though
why does he hate him
love why oh why is he mad at her
um
actually pokemon tweet or something
no i don't know why he's mad actually no
yeah later in this clip he starts
yelling the things that you hear a lot
about uh okay let me keep she's not
she's not gonna [ __ ] you like oh right
that was it i wanna keep it yeah i want
to hear that are telling his community
to do it
[ __ ] are cap [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] are
stitching bro she's not gonna [ __ ] you
she's not gonna [ __ ] you bro
she's not gonna [ __ ] you [ __ ]
then why are you snitching stupid miners
oh hell nah
you know what's funny the real simp is
him he's like the five-year-old who's
got a crush on a girl who flicks her ear
so she notices him i mean dude if
anyone's trying to actually
get her attention it's you dude it's
pathetic it's pretty true s-i-m-p yeah
he is a professional raw dogger by the
way
right
i'm showing love y'all that's what a
shirt says say to go professional
raw dog dogger hell yeah
we're trying to find the roast of the
world that's right yeah well that's
funny because most of his fans are like
eight
right i guess most of his fans are the
uh consequence of raw dogging recent raw
dogging sure so maybe he's just
representing his fan base
pokeman love did i not say that chat did
i not say go show pokeman love
shut up did i not say bro i said
i said w plus ratio isn't that what i
said
that's literally what i said did not say
w plus ratio this guy has literally a
stripper pole in his apartment
um
sorry
not what i said
chad is that not what i said
bro her [ __ ] shot up like 2k so is that
the part about she's not going to [ __ ]
yeah
he went on and on about it i mean it's
like 15 minutes long we don't have to
watch it all but but this is the
sentiment that you see of why people
hate her and other women in gaming it's
like
this insinuation that pokemane who
by all means is not even like
provocatively dressed or scantily clad
or showing cleavage or anything like
that
not that there's anything wrong with
those things but it's just proof that
she's very conservative
successful on her own merits
yet to in the eyes of all these incels
uh it's like she's not gonna [ __ ] you
bro meaning the only reason people are
watching is because she's hot and they
think that they have a chance with her
and they're simps and stuff um no dude
you know that is misogyny you you think
that that's the only reason she could be
successful in truth dude you want a
chance with her you want her attention
and that's why you're doing this it's
pathetic bro you're the simp you're the
simp
you know
i mean you're the same can't you see
that
you guys are the ones begging for
attention man right yeah your comparison
to a
kid uh pushing the girl he has a crush
on elementary schools yeah pretty happy
grow up bro just say hi
if you're so interested
you don't got to send all your chat to
seem like you're like interesting or
important or something like it's just
sad anyway he got suspended for 14 days
he went on instagram live i'm getting to
the new development if you guys i made a
h3 tv not to can be confused with this
channel the h3 tv my channel
uh about this so i'm catching up
the real side of twitch
matthew when you clip this make this a
separate part when i get to it i'm gonna
let you guys know about the real color
or other minorities within the last year
or two over covet i think i likely would
have retired from streaming this year oh
really like i like we would have why
because
feeling like your existence
is friction in the industry that you're
in it's just not fun
like at some point you're like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i want to have a good life
hang out
i just want to play games
you're the only female streamer i know
that
is hated that way
it is not uh
right so this was after he got suspended
for 14 days and so he went on instagram
live and basically doubled down on all
of it and which is i think probably the
motivating factor for them making it
permanent because he clearly was
not apologizing he was
doing the opposite really the number one
uh like show of uh
he went out and tweeted out this picture
of her of without makeup on which
apparently all these pathetic
uh insecure men think is the
the ultimate
own apparently
um
he goes new profile pic and this was
something that a lot of reactionary like
look at her without makeup bro freaking
owned like who where's your god now
simps
a girl without makeup freaking dominated
bro
yeah it's the picture it looks good yeah
this is the picture leafy used in his 12
part series whatever it was uh bullying
her for no reason
a big reveal of his video was that she
had a boyfriend which wasn't true
cool freaking owned bro
you just got wrecked dude look at her
look at a post she picked she posted of
herself right without makeup freaking
own sims
look at her where's your god
checkmate yeah
just uh like an hour ago um if you take
a look at the
discord um
she
posted
something that's probably worth taking a
look at
oh she posted something new
yeah it just looks like she's showing
tired people minimizing the harassment i
received over the past last week to just
l plus ratio so here's a list
okay this is good by the way i've seen
now a lot of streamers and myself have
defended her but i've seen clips of it
like on tick tock and around the web and
they're a lot of the majority of the
little 12 year old
uh
results of raw dogging are still mad at
her for this guy getting permanently
banned who she literally was minding her
business jade on tweet negative hateful
things about me before the hate raid
made youtube videos about me he hate
writing me and told his viewers to spam
l plus ratio but this part matters the
least after i put on follower mode he
told his viewers to follow me so they
can spam me guys follow her follower
yeah we saw that opened up profiles of
my subs and called them snitches for
telling me that he what he was doing
which leads to his viewers messaging my
subs and harassing them telling them to
kill themselves calling them slurs he
yelled if you're from pokey's chat and
you have a penis i'm gonna tell you
right now she's not gonna [ __ ] you bro
uh extreme sexual comments about me
there's more
um
telling people that she's getting [ __ ]
down every night by another n word
ball's deep bro i bet another n-word got
12-incher she's getting a full foot long
up her [ __ ] like okay dude
told people to keep spamming me if he
gets banned on twitch said that i
got him banned from twitch multiple
times
it's twitch decision yeah of course it's
like he does something dumb gets banned
and then blames her like she literally
was minding her own business asked other
streamers to go to war with him
including aiden ross i was asking a russ
to tweet at me dme which increased the
spam i got gifted ninja 100 subs and
asked to
help get him a lesser ban ninja said you
can't raid [ __ ] on twitch
and d john said oh he called her a [ __ ]
while clapping and celebrating ninja
texted his twitch representative to help
him avoid a ban or pretend to
i'll get into that he and then he
changed his profile pic to uh her
without makeup
when i went live on twitch he'd stream
himself reacting to my stream on his ig
live which made me receive even more
harassment
g-dog fans spammed all my social media
platforms
with insult threats etc you can imagine
jessica blevin this is the part i'm
getting to that's ninja's wife dm me
telling me ninja has nothing to be sorry
for and that he never texted his twitch
representative even though i sent her
proof ninja texted me that i'm making a
big mistake when i spoke out about my
experience jessica then threatened to
sue me yeah i'm gonna get that last part
is really good but it's like dude you
are clearly obsessed with her she
doesn't want to have anything to do with
the it's like you're you're tracking her
you get banned and then you're tracking
your live streams on other platforms and
bro just you could have just said hi
maybe she would have liked you
but now you got no shot you blew your
shot yep
damn maybe he found out she had a i
don't know if she has a boyfriend or not
but he's like oh she got a boyfriend i'm
going to rage
incel rage
so that's that but then the really
interesting part came yesterday and this
is an update i haven't talked about
is when ninja's wife
straight threatened to
sue pokeman and which is incredible here
is the clip that started help me step
ninja he'll be step ninja that's just
literally i promise you guys
dijon mustard or whatever his name is
um
went on ninja stream begging for help
how many does is ninja even relevant
love doesn't he get like
he fell off dude he fell off
hard l plus ratio now talk about a real
pleasure
holy crap
wait
literally
this is important okay
i think this was some flaws this is the
moment where it all fell apart yeah this
is the moment
bro can we get an l plus ratio for
freaking ninja on this right now
[Music]
let's get those flosses going everybody
[Music]
point and just walked off into the
sunset
um
well and then he had the whole thing
where he left twitch to go to mixer uh
exclusively which uh microsoft ended up
closing because
nobody was using that service and so i
think that kind of killed all the
momentum of his viewership well that's
kind of interesting because there's
other people that went to mixer came
back to twitch and were successful yeah
shroud which is like what happened i
guess fortnite fell off and he was there
i mean he's just not that entertaining
to be honest he's a child's entertainer
he's a child yeah
you might call him a raw dogger you
could yeah absolutely
it seems like he still gets views though
i mean what is this this is wait yeah
you can see the
those are average uh viewers by no means
well this was 150 000. so this looks
like 20 000 i mean that's not bad
yeah or no it says 2 000
that's quite low for him
anyway here he is
there's negative things i could do i
could by the way
fantasy 14 original like bro are you
even trying
to represent bro are you even trying
what did you just call it isn't this
final what game is this this is final
fantasy 11 it's called 11.
are you sure no i'm not actually no this
is final finance c14 before the whatever
nobody cares yes it is bro i played this
freaking game i played 14 too lovely
fact check that you're right
oh i don't actually know about i think
so
i'm telling you i saw this and i
recognized it immediately he's playing
final fantasy 14 before they overhauled
it i didn't know you could still play
that me neither
no that's for sure well he's just
looking at a video he's not playing it
okay whatever
yeah it's 11. i was right
frick
no he's playing an mmo dude i know 11 is
an mmo that was the original final
fantasy mmo oh yeah oh okay
all right let's just watch who cares
i'm like oh maybe he's joking like maybe
it's just a meme like it doesn't mean
he's actually gonna do it
i am trying to get full [ __ ] benefit
of the doubt at this point
all right all right i'll i'll do it
hey charlie log off
[ __ ] what's her name
yeah because because he's got 14 000
viewers we're not in sub mode and he's
sent his entire chat to [ __ ] asking
for help so he doesn't get paid for
pokemon
by the way ninja's influence has clearly
waned as evidenced by the fact that his
plea for help resulted in his friend
getting permanently banned instead of 14
days so good job there ninja
yeah l plus ratio plus floss at new york
to uh times square in the rain
that [ __ ] video man that [ __ ]
yeah that's up there with the jesse
wellins cringe yeah
can we re-watch the walling screen wow i
haven't thought of that in a long time
that's probably the cringiest video on
the internet
i guess i don't know what you're talking
about okay but let me finish this story
i don't get too sidetracked
all right i'll learn the twitch
environment better
it's a it's a meme dude
anyway he's like yeah i'll do it i'll
ask for help
yeah
did someone say what what's going on
now slim stun he's sleeping the
groundskeeper he's a legend bro all
right all right i sent the text
offer i can't i don't promise i don't
promise a goddamn thing
yeah well you can't i mean you have no
leverage or clout you're like the
biggest l lord ever
that's not true he's pretty rich just
from that one year i can't call him the
biggest lord ever
um cam
yeah this is basically fortnite sent
this to ninja
for a christmas card you fell off
damn
fortnite
fork and knife
night for put a fork knife in him
[Music]
all right
thank you
uh
so blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah ninja says he likes dijon will
stream with him when the band is lifted
and then
ninja dm'd pokey which is really funny
because he i guess pretended to text
twitch
and then so pokey is kind of a badass
for sure for showing all these i think
he said hey just so you just want to
hey so i just want you to know i swear
on my grandfather's life who just passed
away
that i didn't text my twitch rep and you
are making a big mistake
um
you need to up your your collateral
because if your grandpa's already
[ __ ] dead
then that's kind of an empty promise i
was just thinking that it's kind of like
uh seems kind of bullshitty
i swear on the life of george washington
and and the idle threat you are making a
big mistake
i respect people like like i i
when pressed like that it's like don't
give in to these [ __ ] bullies bro
that's just bully tactics you are making
a big mistake
she shows the tax badass
so then jessica ninja's wife and she's
also his manager
uh
sent her this
message
check this [ __ ] out bro
we and this is the kind of text that
sets me off so i have mad respect for
her for putting this out there and
sticking to her guns we are considering
everything defamation of character at
this point and getting our legal team
involved that's copypasta right there
what did she def how did she defame you
[ __ ]
literally all she said was that you were
defending him and you were come on let's
be honest
well like how could she have known
this is where it gets weird to me it's
like he said he published right he did
it he grabbed his phone and started
clicking so i guess i texted it so he's
saying that he lied and that that was
fake and he was just doing it to to get
his fan uh jidon's uh fans off his back
i guess not defamation you're the one
that lied right you're spewing
you're spewing lies to tens of thousands
of people you know twitch you claim you
know his rep and then you know from them
that tyler never reached out to anyone
and again just said that to stop the
harassment in his chat from daejeon
viewers we have clarified everything to
you you are actively bringing harassment
to tyler and i write at the highest
level and we are taking this very
seriously um you guys lied you guys are
the one with the pie on your face y'all
fake texted
and acted like you cared about this dude
it turns out you don't care about anyone
but yourself and you're just a coward
and you didn't actually speak on
anyone's behalf literally lying
thank you hassan
uh here's pokey's response i think
jessica's trying to say that ninja oh
well yeah she tweeted this
jessica's trying to say that ninja
pretended to text his twitch
representative which i'm willing to
accept and cannot disprove i just wanted
the clip out there to show what happened
and then actually incidentally i also
got this text
from
hassan the same day
oh
thank you
uh he sent me this very threatening
message which i have to share with you
guys he said today i'm considering
everything defamation of character at
this point and i'm getting my legal team
involved you're spewing lies to tens of
thousands of people and you know
autonomy you claim to know the size of
my head and that i have i have never had
a less than average sized head and again
just saying that to stop the harassment
in my chat from the leftovers viewers
i've clarified everything to you of
actively bringing harassment to my head
to body ratio right now at the highest
level and we are taking this very
seriously so hassan is threatening
defamation of character we're saying his
head is small you hate to see it you had
to see it
oh i love that it was inevitable
yeah it was inevitable
number one l plus ratio
oh man
uh ninja's involvement specifically
began the day the hate raid
blah blah blah ninja addressed the
situation on his next stream saying he
spoke with dijon mustard about it and
now he can't send his views to hate raid
others
who gives a [ __ ] that's it
damn
but anyway the point is is that ninja's
wife was threatening her in the dms
which i thought was great
that dm is a is a great one yeah that's
an instant classic yeah we are
considering everything
defamation of character at this point
and are getting our legal team involved
that's what i say to my scale every
morning
i'm threatening it
um we gotta go to break but real this is
only 47 seconds long so this is my
favorite and i'm i like jesse i'm
friends with him but man this is the
best clip on the internet
up guys
thank you for having me
if you guys all know who i am my name is
jesse wellins and i am a youtube creator
so
i am here
to
um
payback
uh if you guys didn't know need to be
payback
i'm bo um
yes great game
but all right all set aside
i'm a youtube creator nifty payback it's
coming out
i got my boy marcus executive producer
here he is the producer of the game
thank you
[Laughter]
i'm bombing but he couldn't even get the
words out um
so what what happened there there's just
teleprompter [ __ ] he came on the show
and explained that uh he wasn't he
didn't know he was about to come on and
i guess the teleprompter was moving too
fast and it was just a perfect storm and
just kind of ran away oh poor guy and
you become self-aware in the moment and
then it's just it's over poor [ __ ]
guy dude
oh boy all right we gotta go to break
will we bring out some taco bell or
something afterwards
uh if you as you wish sam we got the tb
and i don't mean tuberculosis all right
let's go to a break
when we come back
taco bell time
exciting let's see what love thinks
about american fast food let's go
let's go i'm excited
time to take a short break
thank you to mid mobile
is saving more and spending less is one
of your top goals for 2022
why are you still paying insane amounts
of money every month for wireless it's
time to switch to mint mobile the
easiest way to save money this year it's
the first company to sell premium
wireless services online only and
mipmobile lets you maximize your savings
with a plan starting at just fifteen
dollars a month
we put dan on mint mobile and guess what
it's great minty fresh that's right oh
i'm into fresh that's right the truth is
it's the same freaking it's on the same
uh
uh hardware it's on the same bro it's
all the same stuff if you're still yeah
you still wanna i'm one of those big
boys
uh you're taking the l you're taking the
l plus a ratio
uh that's gonna be a dead meme stone i
mean it is kind of a dead meme yeah but
i can't
it's not say plus ratio when somebody
says else yeah
well anyway guys listen
min mobile it's the same thing it's
great uh for people looking for extra
savings this year
min mobile is offering premium wireless
for just 15 bucks a month by going
online only and eliminating traditional
cost of retail
uh mint mobile is passing significant
savings on to you all plants come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network use your own phone with any
mint mobile plan and keep your same
phone number along with all of your
existing contacts and with mint mobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
that you never use switch to mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 buckaroonies a month
that's right get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mint mobile.com h3 that's mint mobile
dot com slash h3 cut your wireless bill
to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com h3
curology is a game-changing custom
skincare made for you by a dermatology
provider they create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goals whether you're tackling acne
clogged pores skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else you start
by taking a short online skin quiz and
uploading photos and if it's a good fit
they'll ship the formula right to your
door even as your name right on the
bottle so i've been using curology for a
few months now since we started work
with them gotta say
love it
this is what i've always been looking
for i love
i like the whole dermatology face care
thing but
going to a dermatologist such a pain in
the ass it's so expensive you got to
work with your insurer or pay out of
pocket
this is streamlined you take the quiz
you send the photo they formulate a
perfect skin regimen for you they send
you the face cream
the moisturizer and then the dermatology
provided product you get into three
action system and honestly my skin has
never felt better it's just nice to feel
like i'm doing something about it uh
it's beautiful i recommend it big time
getting started with curology just like
i did get started with curology just
like i did with a free 30-day trial boom
curology.com h3 pay just five bucks for
the shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash h3 to
start your free 30-day trial you can
cancel at any time prescription subject
to consultation give it a shot i love it
thank you liquid iv keeping us all
hydrated around the office big fan of
this product dan is mixing it up right
now it's basically mixing it up it's
basically water plus
it's a
water
xl plus
you know
basically it enhances your water it's
more hydrating than water you boost it
with electrolytes and
um
vitamins and all kind there's all
different kinds there's one for like
caffeine for a boost in the morning
there's one for immunity boost there's
one for hydrating boost which one you
got there i'm on the third one that
hydration multiplier powered by ctt
cellular transport technology non-gmo
electrolyte drink mix watermelon
yes it does wow well hey there's a lot
in that thing you don't even have to
think about it dude
i feel great sometimes i don't feel like
drinking coffee because it messes up my
stomach and you hit some of that it's
like drinking water that wakes you up in
the morning
it's got the caffeine it tastes great
you'll love it it contains five
essential vitamins
b356 12 and vitamin c comes with three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks made with premium
ingredients non-gmo and free from gluten
dairy and soy
it's got the science of cellular
transport technology whatever the
frick that is it's designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream it's
been served liquid iv has been donated
over 19 million
they've donated over 19 million servings
globally
you know sweet grab your liquid iv in
bulk nationwide at costco or get 25 off
when you go to liquidive.com and use the
code h3 at checkout that's 25 percent
off anything you order when you use the
promo code h3 at
liquidive.com better hydration today at
liquidive.com promo code h3 thank you
thank you
harry's razors thank you thank you
harry's makes the greatest
razors in the world at the best price
you gotta love it it's that time of year
to start fresh and with a new resolution
whether you're trying to manage your
finances financials better or just
trying to look better harry's can help
okay
that's a big problem a big promise
harris is an award-winning razor brand
that makes a full range of grooming
essentials and they were founded on the
belief you shouldn't have to choose
between an incredible shape and a prayer
a fair price well they got a good deal
for our listeners to start the new year
with some savings new customers can
redeem a harry's trial set for just
three bucks
when you go to harrys.com h3 did i read
that right
three bucks harry's dot com slash h3
harry's delivers a close comfortable
shave at a fair price still as low as
two dollars per blade and harry's blades
are designed to stay sharp longer in a
recent study guys who shave four times a
week said their eighth shave was as
smooth as their first
harry's is giving their best offer to
our listeners new hairy customers can
redeem a starter set you get a five
blade razor a weighted handle foaming
shave gel with aloe and a travel cover
to protect your blades when you're on
the go that's 13 value for just three
bucks
there's truly never been a better time
to try harry so go to harrys.com h3 to
try harry's today thank you thank you
all right let's talk i want to talk
about vanilla ice teaming up with the q
on wrapper actually yeah
so the guy that vanilla ice is teaming
up with he's a q anon rapper
for ghiado blow
you know we put that in the doc
not that there's really much of a
difference anymore but i'm not sure he's
actually a q a rapper he might just be
this is just like the mega rapper yeah
yeah i i know this guy right so he made
a music video quite named rodeo with
your
favorite boy
vanilla
is vanilla ice confirmed magga
uh
he's confirmed based in red pill is what
he is
i mean he must be uh like this
you'll see in the the lyrics as well
it's it's got some maga themes going on
here am i gonna get claimed am i going
to go uh i uh re-uploaded it no claim
this seems to be an independent
adventure well it has 40 000 views so
yeah
what does that put on the billboard top
100 40 000. uh let me check that real
quick um
if i ain't if this is oh it didn't
charge i don't know
if this is the guy i think oh wait this
is vanilla ice it's on vanilla ice's
channel
oh no wonder it has so little because i
think this guy is pretty popular the
the for guidance
blow
it's one of my favorite types of cheese
vanilla ice performed at trump's new
year's eve party wait hold on what'd it
be vanilla ice performed at trump's new
year's eve party
i just found um this is this is uh
forgino blows uh
channel and his let's go brandon
has a 2.4 million views so this is his
most popular one actually
oh thank you sam the girl scream make
him hot make him melt like ice cream
i don't think
oh he did have enough okay
bro do you even own this beat it wasn't
this this is a you got sued
it's queen it's a queen's david bowie
queen yeah yeah like
you're really gonna use that now
and they have another collab together
where they have the ninja turtles in it
because no ice was in ninja turtles too
and has song in there and i don't think
they have their rights his only that
song for being real yo if i'm being real
go ninja vanilla ice cameo and ninja
turtles
blew my mind when i was a kid yeah i
thought that was the [ __ ] i was so
sick bro go ninja go
dude break dancing on the shell
unfortunately i imagine a lot of our
audience might be too young to have
experience hold that glory good yeah i i
don't i think the magic's lost it
probably looks like
just horrifyingly bad anyway here let's
go brandon by
forgiato blow
as you can hear the chance from the
crowd
let's go brandon brandon you told me you
were gonna kind of hang back those first
two
americans screaming let's go
okay
let me stop you there
man where's the closed caption i don't
want to miss a word
dude what
the dude can't even talk without getting
auto-tuned
you hear the auto-tune work in overtime
he's not even singing
like what the hell bro yeah they got
that [ __ ] all the way up the machine is
smoking it was working overtime yo 2.5
million views no [ __ ] white people
listen to this [ __ ] let's go brandon and
god bless america you know what's funny
is when a dude like this makes a rap
song you see all these like boomer ass
old racist white people are like i like
rap now
i get it i hate most rap but this is
actually pretty good i actually hate rap
music but this is awesome
this is i'm like rapping over some
skinner do something like that oh yeah
bro
what they mean is well as long as
there's a white man doing it i like it
[Music]
sleepy joe ain't got no support sleepy
joe hunter bottom better show up to
court yeah
um
why is this have any views
100 bucks this is straight like doggy
[ __ ] tear
soundcloud rap i mean what the [ __ ] bro
like jake paul has better bars than this
yeah i ain't taking no
vaccines don't ask me
the republican party is beyond [ __ ]
where like the their platform is
synonymous where it's like [ __ ] joe
biden
i ain't taking no vaccine
and ma and no masks either i mean bro
these are public health issues how the
[ __ ] did this get turned into a let's go
brandon thing
my grandma is 83
that [ __ ] just gonna be dead to me
when that omicron be coming through yeah
let's not get her vaccinated or messed
up
nana's about to take a dip
r.i.p nana dude
let's see the other nana yeah
well that that's that's not nana
yeah you think nana is gonna survive
omicron i like a homie behind her
on the left side
yeah on the left side with his goatee
yeah it looks like a badass wait which
one this
guy's
is
is that homer swim simpson
oh [ __ ] he does have that homer it's
like oh the vagina face yeah
or his face looks like a vagina
i ain't taking that vaccine boy
i would love to see a channel 5 video
shot at this shoot oh yeah interviewing
these people
and i ain't wearing no masks they're
nasty i ain't wearing no masks they
nasty
yeah the master nasty is he's just
surrounded by these like just
hooting hogs just red sweaty faces
to slaughter boys
come on now piggy
and all you liberals better stop trying
to harass me you know we try to stop the
still sparing me republican
[Music]
i don't know what to say i mean
the country is so divided and like
nothing i'm sure these are all nice
great people but it's like there's
probably of two years of education
i do think they're good people if you
got to know them yeah but they're just
they're living in an alternate reality
where
covet is fake trump won the election
no vaccines no mask it's just it's it's
hard when the on the opposite platform
is pure insanity and um
also where this is good music i mean
that is unforgivable world i think we
need to secede from the nation
you're very special
but straight up if they if if there's a
secession and like they start a new
confederacy
straight
poverty immediately the most
impoverished country in the world no
education no health care
full-on diabetes
awesome
proud americans and pbs i hear violence
let's go brandon let's go brandon let's
go brandon let's go brandon
let's go
[Applause]
[ __ ] joe
joe
let's go brandon that's also a new
favorite among americans winning a big
race shout out to sean kennedy
just like them totally not a
coastal he is sean handy is one of us
boys
not like he's buying up affordable
houses all across america isn't that
something he's doing sean hannity got
busted buying
he's taking place in something where
he's buying up like uh cheap houses he's
got like thousands of them
he's just like us boys
talladega well the reporter actually
thinks they're saying a little white
power sign in there right i mean that's
what that is right
when that guy is doing it yeah probably
well you mean because a-okay yeah no
that's straight white power they're
doing they're making a point of it yeah
in a political video it's like yeah
that's what it means
why do by the way did you see anyone in
this entire video that's not white
southwest don't ask me
legit is there one oh
i mean is the main guy
a person of color i really can't tell
yeah he's [ __ ] pink that's his color
no there's not a single everybody is
like white
like pink white you know what i mean
yeah no i definitely know pig
white americans
while
and
let's go brandon let's go brandon let's
go the let's go brandon thing is is code
for [ __ ] joe biden but you're wearing a
shirt that says [ __ ] bite in and you're
saying it also a lot you could just drop
the whole brand stuff this stick yeah
yeah he could have written this a lot
more clever
let's go
let's go brandon that's also a new
favorite among americans winning a big
race brandon brown after his big so
diverse that crowd
actually thinks they're saying cheering
granted when you listen closely
no the people straight what power
[ __ ] [ __ ] brandon why power
see this is why i would pump the brakes
when you said i'm sure these are great
people um i guess yeah i guess
[ __ ] hey you know what i don't like
liberals why power
i'm just a good old american why power
death to all jews by power
ain't no ain't nothing wrong with being
a conservative death toll jews
ain't nothing wrong with hate and joe
biden all black people need to go to
jail [ __ ] you about white power
black people just need to go back where
they're from
yeah you know they ain't
they try to spend it on the pizza
but you can never play the patriots i
told you joe you went viral again no
they weren't chanting let's go brandon
at all you the american people of every
reason to be angry at joe biden he is
failing this country around every turn
every american is paying the price the
world is paying the price
[Music]
why power let's go brandon let's go to
the comments eh
let's go brandon god bless america and
white power
dude straight up included white power in
his video that's crazy
south africa another country great on
the racial issues shout out from south
africa
finally a movement i can get behind
yeehaw let's go brandon it's a whole new
genre of music
with three hits in the top 10. why power
another ship from south africa holy [ __ ]
popular song in south africa what do you
make of that
i have some suspicions
let's go brandon it's a worldwide
movement
switzerland okay
from the uh so the national socialist
party of switzerland sends their regards
this is awesome i love conservative
media they're so talentless [ __ ]
creeps dude
here's a kyle rittenhouse song as well
oh i want that we still haven't watched
the vanilla ice one that set this whole
thing off he also his website is pretty
[ __ ] uh pretty gnarly too can you
find out that story about sean hannity
buying like yeah it says he
he owns over 870 properties in seven
states reportedly yeah family houses
salt of the earth celta dirk just like
me brother oh here let me pay my rent mr
hannity
oh i'm late in my rant mr hannity is
that okay get the [ __ ] out
yeah this is my favorite genre of music
right now let's keep watching i love
this [ __ ]
well i've walked through the smoke on
stage so wait let's watch the
that's on vanilla ice's channel you
won't find that okay let's watch the um
where's the kyle renting house one
it's not a music video no but just the
lyrics are uh and the comments are
very
interesting
yeah so kyle rittenhouse who you know
the kyle renton house thing i haven't
really touched on that much
here's the thing
we can assume
you know as he was acquitted in court
let's just assume that what he did was
self-defense okay
and you know what he shouldn't have gone
to jail whatever let's just assume that
for the sake of my next argument
okay
he was doing self-defense
now
what exactly has this man this young man
child uh is he 17 dan is that right
when he killed the people
so this child what has this child
achieved other than murdering people in
self-defense
what has he achieved other than
murdering people and he's being propped
up like a hero in the conservative party
they are literally promoting
a vigilante who murders people and his
sole achievement is that he killed
people
straight the [ __ ] up
he is a child who has killed and mammed
people he's getting standing ovations at
the cpac
he's doing the world tour on every
conservative uh uh
show
for the sole achievement of killing
people
and getting away with it is this someone
to be celebrated like sure maybe he
shouldn't have gone to jail but is this
the person we want
to celebrate is this our hero
are you asking me yes the answer is no i
would not like to celebrate him so
anyway
kyle ridden house white power
[ __ ] the jews
they empower
already better than what he wrote
all right here we go
about to slap it hard american american
call me kyle
come on now yeehaw baby
what
he just steals beets you can call me owl
[Music]
it's like the most flamboyant paul simon
like
hippy dippy song you really gonna
appropriate you can call me al yeah
yeah it's that's that's probably gonna
claim just the sample you can't well i'm
dying to hear this that's so funny
maybe we'll include it for our
members
okay i mean we have i i know the vanilla
ice one won't get claimed
okay it's just maybe a remix
yeah so you can call me al
this how is this
hardcore
this is the lamest beat ever
if you need a bodyguard
oh
no
[ __ ] way
this is giving me insane clown posse
vibes
no [ __ ] way dude
oh yeah by the way um
sean hannity salt of the earth yeehaw
he's just like us bar
that's sean hannity
he owns a shell company that has spent
at least 90 million dollars on more than
870 homes
yeehaw rentals for low-income families
come on now
[Applause]
bought a bunch of these uh houses in
2013 after banks foreclosed on them
he swooped up my house when after i
foreclosed he's a good man
he let me stay in it too but he raised
my rent every year at the same time he
was criticizing barack for all the
foreclosures in the u.s
while literally buying up what a piece
of [ __ ]
hog definition of a hog
come on now piggy it's feeding time
[Music]
though 27 000 views on this one let's
just reflect that he's singing about a
17 year old boy
okay
a grown-ass man
singing a love song to a 17 year old boy
oh wow nice camp
well done wait what is this scam the
screen well this is the music video for
the original oh i guess i haven't seen
it
i wonder how paul simon would feel about
this for cover
[Music]
come on kyle
it's like carpenter yeah exactly kyle
you jew
what power kyle
got me cat americans
[Music]
walks down the street it says all these
people headed in my direction ar-15 gold
and blessings
my name is kyle and they said why my
head my direction i shot i killed two
men and i'm aimed to third it was white
power floated
that float that that flow was heavy and
hard wait let me this guy spits bar mad
bars
conservatives this is your hero this is
your musician checkmate
that's in my direction oh yeah let me go
back
[Music]
and remember he could have re-recorded
that
he could have reached
one that was his
one
that was his best take we're talking
about forgiato blow here
people headed in my direction
shame it's a shame they got me fighting
wars before puberty it's a shame it's a
shame i wonder what the judging jury can
do to me
like a right now
call say kyle let's get it
[Music]
sorry people had to die that day but
american patriots never
[Music]
yo he just defiled the most iconic
baseline
and classic
rock history absolutely
[Applause]
not guilty
[Music]
you
how much you want to bet the people
listening don't even know that this is
you can call me owl by paul simon
all right i heard the comments are good
thank you kyle for being the only one
with enough balls to save this country
black power oh
the country's been saved he's been saved
he killed two he killed why are they
still so upset that's it's enough ball
singular
he's got enough ball for the both of us
fergario needs to start putting his
lyrics in this video so we can sing
along amen brother why power
another right on target song thanks for
keeping your music real not guilty amen
why power amen
i know and agree with the meaning behind
the song along with all the others
self-defense but my name kyle renton
house myself and this goes
way too hard bruh
new party song straight banger it's a
vibe why power
hey i mean
i'm just reading what's there what's
like you know the unwritten he straight
up was showing white power signs in his
last music video
uh
semper fi love that
i'm glad the marines are on board let's
go brandon white power
the marines is for white men only
bro you absolutely killed this one
paul simon would be jealous
love the vibe smooth yeah that was
such a smooth flow
here's a here's one uh
the that dislike by me was never
intended
oh my god my finger accidentally tapped
the dislike button hope you understand
forgaddio
forgiato
i totally like this song keep it up
that's awesome straight boomer energy
his rap name is so funny too forgiados
are rims
and then blow fortunato blow
nice well they are rooms
yeah it's like a rap generator name
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so let's get to the um
that matter at hand shall we i want to
hear this vanilla ice one
well i walk through the smoke on stage
and the girls scream make them hot make
a melt like ice cream
that that it's not on his page it's on
vanilla ice's page yep so let's go
vanilla
ice youtube channel it's in the link too
let's see if that works it did work so
what do we got here wait vanilla ice
unwrapping a silver play button hang the
[ __ ] on
you
tube something we did not have
in the 90s i know
youtube and smartphones did not happen
until 2000 yeah we [ __ ] know that
wow this was filmed three months ago
dude like are you still saying that
he's like man i wish they were i will i
wish anyway did i mention i still wish
it was the 90s
why power
100. this is equivalent to a drum roll
drinking a beer i hope you're better at
opening christmas presents
and there it is
boom what's that say presented to
vanilla ice for passing one hundred
thousands what's that say i look can't
read
you gotta read it for me white power
subscribe to the real deal
holyfield the vanilla ice youtube
channel get it how you live it exclusive
content making things happening
free songs free videos that's what we do
we give it back to the fans
just waiting for four more 100k sub
buttons he thinks he gets one every 100k
why is he
is he signing his own
yeah he there seems to be some kind of
arrangement where
he doesn't know what's going on and
someone else is clearly
running this channel because
they're like we have five hundred
thousand now he's like what five hundred
thousand what what power
well good good for him he's not glued to
the analytics
[Music]
okay chill dude
don't they sign
hall of fame i records it
yeah
yeah i you know that's true i sign all
of my uh
whenever i get a new piece of teddy
fresh i sign it
just so i know it's mine makes me feel
good all right rodeo is this the one i
believe so all right so here's the fresh
original oh my god
rodeo
featuring
forge auto blow and stoney
dude bro is the guy in the background
the left and he is so awkward
[Music]
pay attention to his movement
[Music]
show her off with the rodeo
[Music]
that's my lady jewelry dripping like ice
cream ice ice baby got me up bro you
gotta stop with the ice ice baby we get
it yeah
[ __ ] hell bro time to move on
hotter than wet dreams okay i guess
he's got that he's got that luigi drip
drill
[Music]
[Music]
i have to say compared to the the to the
uh
for 4g audio whatever the [ __ ]
white power boy
he sounds like rembrandt or he sounds
like mozart compared to
forgiato
no wonder he invited him on he seems
like a musical genius by comparison
i'm going to start on brocco you know
it's friday
yeah this just straight up a rebecca
black remix
you know it's friday
it's after thursday
it's before sun or saturday
the only thing we're missing is a
patrice wilson feature
[Music]
you want to take home that blue ribbon
girl
imma show you off at the rodeo i'm gonna
ride you like the bull get a perfect
score you're trying to buck me like a
you try to buck me because i'm straight
i'm gonna get off of ya
it's like the rodeo
white power
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next door
that that biggie was first in show three
years in a row
mr blow is the grandson is this is a
this is more trivia so mr blow
is that what we're calling him now we're
putting some respect on it yeah i'm
trying to show him the respect mr blow
is the grandstand the grandson of stuart
arnold the auto
trader publishing empire founder oh so
he's rich too yeah yeah yeah supposedly
what does that work does it say let me
see like
he must have inherited i love that salt
of the earth boy
auto
trader all these guys are like that it's
like how kid rock is also
like
you know midwestern royalty somehow
i'm one of you i smoke bud light and
smoke cigarettes
and then i go home to my 20 million
dollar mansion
with servants i have butlers
white power
all
right just pack your bags and we out you
with the king of the south you ain't
never coming back baby this ain't for
clout you so beautiful to me cowboy
boots with a t you got your mama smile
with some brand new double d you know
it's friday
and i just got paid baby
it's friday it's friday
gotta get down on friday look at that
trans am or firebird in the background
sick
leave with them track there's more money
john deere's can we get in here
actually so this is a huge collab with
iced tea wait do you see his next collab
with rebecca black definitely not with
iced tea i
like vanilla
yeah but no this this one's gonna be a
banger i can't wait it's friday
it's friday
gotta get down on friday
dude this this beard's kind of wild
yeah it gives me pedo vibes straight up
the cutout i guess it's so he could show
off the tattoos there why power
his family's definitely loaded
i can't find how much they're worth
they're loaded yeah their property alone
is worth 11 million do they live in an
11 million house
uh that was his father's property um
well you know and wherever he lives
which is i don't know what state but
that's probably like the biggest house
in the state you know
yeehaw
i believe they're from florida
oh there's
there's expenses
and shake it all about
drop in bars
[Music]
yo this guy's so far he's stealing bars
from the hokey pokey
what happened to stony dude bro he
didn't have a verse he was just coming
[Music]
also giving me kind of uh big nick kind
of looks like big nick
stoney got some charm maybe he could be
my romeo giddy up giddy up get up baby
hop up in my whip get it i'm the type to
open the door before you see it
what a gentleman bro
this dude opens the door
they said chivalry was dead
she said she like horses well i do too i
like clydesdale
no
[ __ ] shot
dude straight up just said i heard you
like horses well i do too no rhyme
no meter
just straight up i also like horses
[Music]
peak
magga art
this is your the world that they want to
build this is the the theme song of the
new concept
and hey okay so at the very beginning of
this i was like oh i don't know if uh
this guy's actually queuing on he's just
well i just went to stoney dudebros
twitter
and just the other day he tweeted this
11 11 thing that that is uh
that's q anon code
that's like the great awakening [ __ ]
back to that tweet oh i thought it was
11-11 make a wish
that's what i was gonna say 10. you
could be the first person to like that
tweet from the podcast
[ __ ] well 11 11.
what
no yeah i want you know we we see you
stoney tony the patriot yeehaw i like
horses too stealing it
you should write that i like horses too
brother
zero lights brother
i'm the first i'm with you just write i
like horses too comma brother
exclamation you should write j t r h n b
r
and then
no bucket required brother
just the right height no bucket required
i like horses too brother
hell yeah you mean
wait let's go back because i'm like fire
maybe he could be my romeo
giddy up baby yeah this guy just say he
could be my romeo like bro what be my
romeo like hang on hang on because
that's did he just come out of the
closet hang on i'm gonna take you to the
rodeo maybe we could go see
[Music]
[Music]
she said she like horses well i do too
fire bro
that's so fire
i like clydesdales belgians even rory's
too i like how the 488 go fast like
broom she likes tony damn we're all
going fast like vroom
fire
country i'm like nah girl hurt you like
them cowboys
[Music]
baby won't you come roll with me i'ma
take it to the rodeo
show you are better throw me off at the
rodeo
look at how like
how comfortable he is
[Music]
he's dropping zero like tweets like damn
can you see what other tweets he's got
i'm kind of interested i want to see
what other
i'm just fascinated by
dude bro
stoney dude bro yeah i love stony dude
bro
i like him
me too i like hor oh people already
liking it they don't even know what
we're talking about nice primus gif uh
oh this is cam yeah nice cam
well yeah our audience is probably gonna
be pretty confused
oh there's another one truck trump truck
[ __ ] yeah i can't get enough yeah this
is forgiato
come on patriots
i just made a song with vanilla eyes six
likes
hell yeah brother you're doing it you're
doing it stoney all right here we go
forgi auto blow trump truck ah yeehaw
i think this is
how i was raised
showing off his truck hell yeah wait you
got that you got to see the other side
[Music]
this guy what drives this
[Music]
i love trump i wanna [ __ ] him
i love that man he's i heard he's got a
big one
let me get that handsome that hog i want
to show it off at the rodeo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are editing out his license plate with a
picture trump said look at this shitty
tracking watch this
[Music]
so he's talking about how he saved his
family but we all know they're extremely
wealthy
and don't need help
also the song's only a minute long
i think he's just showing off his
truck i don't think he's actually
amazing it's really fast
it's for you
[Music]
look at that editing on this
[Music]
where is he he is like like this has got
to be like there's nothing in sight look
how
it's rural look at that country road
it's rural america
ain't nobody around here boy
that's why he likes it
that's the way i like it white power
is this another one yeah it's just a
clip of another song he had with vanilla
ice oh my god
frequent collaborators
this is not the first time they have
worked together there's also a video of
ride the horse featuring mr blow and
uh
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
he's literally doing the hokey pokey
again in this song listen
your whole career is built on stealing
the hokey pokey dude what kind of [ __ ]
is this
[Music]
ride the horse ride the horse
ride the horse ride the horse ride the
horse now urban cowboy sold to the woman
in the front row
yeah we on our
radio all right i can't do this
damn
what culture
incredible stuff here guys
so i guess we should do the second ad
break and then do the predictions second
break we said we were only gonna do one
all right right but also uh we only have
about 10 minutes left so i think we uh
yeah we went a little too far down the
stoney dude so then wait what should we
do we have the joe rogan or jordan
peterson beef there's so much i mean
you're gonna want to talk about that for
like 30 minutes a piece right do we got
anything quick just because let's talk
about logan paul before that becomes
stale because that that's
pretty
let's see logan paul
says he lost 3.5 million
on fake pokemon cards we actually talked
about it right before he opened it and
it was pretty obvious to anyone that he
had bought a fake
uh
a fake box but now what's real
interesting is that he's been doing like
a whole i lost 2.5 million dollar tour
buy my products do all this and then you
find out that the company actually
reimbursed him
they straight seller or whatever yeah
they gave him his money back so it's
like he's getting all this social clout
for having got scammed at a 3.5 million
but actually he got to keep the money
number one on youtube trending and got
to make a lot of content out of it
pretty cool
scammed
i lost three million five hundred no you
didn't
i lost three thousand three million 500
no you didn't
so yeah we're in chicago but actually i
mean it is an interesting story but i'm
so suspicious about the the
the conditions surrounding it it just
seems like a fake story and i'll tell
you why
everybody in the pokemon community who
knows anything
said this was fake the so even the
serial number was fake
right yeah when we look i guess
what started this whole
uh unveiling that it was all fake was
there's some forum in the corner some
obscure corner of the internet that's
all about pokemon trading cards and
everything and some user on there did
like a deep dive on this box
and they had a whole bun that's a whole
slew of reasons why they were suspicious
but yeah the
most obvious by far was
there was an error in the serial number
on the side of the box which as soon as
i saw that i was like you don't even
need to talk about the rest of this
serial number it's obviously fake yeah
it's fake
yeah um they did a whole deep dive and i
think we talked about it on our last
show before we left i remember talking
about it somewhere but there was a
whole shitload of reasons
you know and the thing is the this
person had been trying to sell this pack
and no serious buyer had bought it
because they were all like it's fake
it's just sounds good
people who wanted to come buy it were
being said they can't come inspect it in
person yeah it's a big red flag yeah so
i don't know i feel like this could be
just like some [ __ ] cloud play
if floyd paid me
in full
maybe i'd be a little higher on that
list you know but yeah the [ __ ]
pokemon cards too
three and a half million dollars he's
crying that he wasn't higher on the list
of top earning creators
dumbass freak [ __ ] jake was too jake
was saying that it was wrong that he
made more
well jake i think actually did have a
crazy year because he had so many big
boxing events
and
but
i don't know why logan would have made
that much money he had one fight that he
apparently didn't get paid for
right
he's got so many other things going on
and he's he's oh he did a bunch of like
nft he's about to say all the pump and
dumps yeah he participated he was a
prolific pump and dumper this year yeah
is my favorite coin
yo and he goes yo i just found this coin
i don't know who made this thing
but anyway i voiced all the animations
crazy coincidence right
on some gi joes three and a half million
dollars on [ __ ] gi joe i cannot
believe it that was a sad day that was a
very sad day we should
we should talk about this a little bit
because i think there's gonna be a
little bit deeper of a story here yeah
you can't just you can't just scam
someone out of out of millions and
millions and millions of dollars like
that right
uh well i don't know you do it all many
times this year you tell me
like
apparently you can without legal
consequences i mean what contract did
they signed
no yeah of course it's fraud what are
you guys debating you [ __ ]
whoever made it committed fraud
logan don't act like you don't know what
fraud is
oh man i don't know i don't know what's
like what goes down to a judge or
anything yeah because by the way it
looks like it looks like we have the
group of people
who are actively doing this and are like
whoever made that box is all is
long gone dude
like
if this is real by the way
right
if any of it's which i'm doubting i'm
i'm doubting
but do you have the let me watch the
clip of when he opened it because i feel
like
whoever scammed him if it is real
is a straight up phooper trooper because
last or last year or two years ago gosh
when this pokemon craze began we did a
sketch where we opened a fake box
of pokemon cards and inside was the
gulf war trading cards and the peter or
the robin hood men in tights not mini
tights no uh the kevin cosby yeah a
trading card
and pretty much exactly the same [ __ ]
in fact i would even say that our box
that we made was more convincing
you can see how fake this [ __ ] is good
sign
what
why are they so puffy
why they're so puffy though
see how the shape doll they don't look
right
they don't look right
you don't look right
[Music]
i'm sorry but when you're buying
3.5 million dollars of like rare trading
cards or something there's something
called um provenance i believe you have
to prove like the origin
of the box where it came from where it's
been who's held it nobody's gonna drop
3.5 million dollars on something this
obviously [ __ ] fake it's
[ __ ] i'm calling this whole thing
[ __ ] interesting
like what's the prominence what's the
provenance or whatever the [ __ ] the word
is a b or there's this whole i have no
idea what you're talking about there's a
thing in an art and collectibles yeah
where you have to ch track the whole
lineage of the of the thing
provenance yeah providence okay
um
well provenance refers to the history of
the ownership of a painting or work of
art yeah that that's because he
supposedly went through this agency
right that specializes in verifying
collectibles and everything baseball
cards right
but
that element of the story
seems very suspicious to me as well
because why would a company like that
risk their reputation on something so
obviously someone needs to have they
made us can someone see if they made a
statement because this if it's not true
would be definitely
defamatory i mean it's definitely
causing damage to their reputation
yeah i mean how could you ever trust
that company to uh to verify it so i
wonder if they've made a statement
because i feel like
there's got to be something coming from
them on this issue
yeah but provenance basically is like
the most important thing improving
authenticity and expensive pieces of art
or collectibles you're tracking the
beginning of its existence its origin
story where it came from where it was
the owner the ownership the guide to
authenticity
yeah exactly whatever
they made a statement
i am reading an article about it right
now trying to see in march 2021 we were
asked to provide our good faith opinion
and verify that the pokemon case had not
been previously opened or tampered with
we evaluated it and in our opinion the
case was in its original state this past
saturday we opened that case to verify
our opinion and we're extremely
disappointed to learn it was inauthentic
we have authenticated tens of thousands
of sealed card products for nearly 20
years and have meticulously developed a
structure and framework to provide our
expert opinion we are re-evaluating our
approach to all sealed cases going
forward we have also decided to halt the
review of pokemon or yu-gi-oh cases or
boxes until we assess and revise our
process
to avoid this happening again what is
this only has 400 likes what is this
this is their instagram page
that's a big company bbc well not big
but they apparently are prominent
collectibles
like you said in baseball cards i guess
specifically
um so i don't know why they
were asked to do a pokemon card thing uh
if that's not their specialty but
so it seems like at least someone said
the story is i mean legit if they made
that statement but they someone said
written on a phone on a phone notepad i
mean i agree what the [ __ ] is what kind
of statement is this
it's like a serious thing i mean
y'all authenticating 2018 gi joe
blasters
what the why oh what is
this well i mean that seems pretty
definitive that they weren't part of the
uh
whatever fantasy that you're you're
saying that this all is because yeah
it's not looking good they would not
risk their reputation
for the sake of a bit with logan paul
what the [ __ ] bro
this whole thing is just like gullible
morons then
yeah i don't know are these guys really
legit like here's another press release
it's on a notepad
who are they are they the article that i
found is about how their credibility is
being called in question so i mean this
is definitely very damaging to them this
is a huge story and um you know they
might be in some trouble because yeah i
can't imagine anyone being willing to
go to them for verification after this
isn't there like the
cornerstone verify authenticity
companies i mean this these cameras
apparently this is this is one of them
from what from what i understand again
they they don't have a reputation for
pokemon cards which is why
it is strange that that's who they they
went to this company maybe the others
were too busy or unavailable i don't
know but um
but within the baseball card world which
evidently is huge oh and that in the
weird to me the analysis that i was
reading of the pokemon collector who was
saying it was fake he's like
also on top of all that they straight
and just mailed it to him
the package something that valuable you
would they just
nailed him yeah 3.5 million
straight up just mail yeah
yeah a bunch of people in the community
were just saying that there's a bunch of
flags there's like announcements close
to you maybe the camera shot look at
that yeah i know i'm it's new you're new
me what are you close you want me to
scoot back i'm just shocked by it you
can see all the details in your face and
[ __ ] um it's a disgrace to a but yeah
there was like grammatical errors ripped
off the [ __ ] pokemon sorry they're
fine no just yeah just a bunch of errors
there seems to be no reviews of the
people selling it a bunch of red flags
got ripped off the [ __ ] pokemon cards
too
oh wait i was watching this hang on see
i'll see how there's they're like
they're curvy and very light
they don't look right
okay let's get it going let's open more
oh my god
i'm sorry but y'all are dumb as hell
oh my god
that should look good
i mean you're saying you think this
whole thing is fake
he's a pretty good actor
he looks pretty uh distressed about this
he's got all those guns there too it's
fake
man it's like he's seeing colors for the
first time yeah totally
yeah
these glasses just changed my life yeah
right
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] why doesn't this
one say first edition on it dude that
looks like the fake pack we made yeah it
really does straight up just printed
on
thin cardboard
i mean it's not even a smart fake
because
okay
[Music]
ian called the guy who bought the cards
from the poke pimp whoa the hell ian
that's just your shot now closer closer
damn it
yo like it's not even a good fake the
boxes are like shitty and if you're
gonna fake it at least put a pack of
pokemon cards in it so it has the same
weight and [ __ ] why would you put gi joe
cards
well maybe they do have the same weight
i imagine they literally were like it
feels light
that was the first thing they said it
feels like
yeah it's a shame they didn't get those
good golf war yeah
at least then it could recoup some of
the value did we ever get those rated
and certified i've been waiting for
those yeah why
there was a whole thing that because of
the people like logan paul
uh starting the whole pokemon card uh
craze the rating agencies became so
overwhelmed that they closed submissions
for like months at a time shortly after
i still want those submitted bro i don't
even know where they are now after i
want my george bush is rated and
certified you don't know where they are
dan i mean they're here somewhere but we
just moved uh i hope they're in safe
keeping
those are so valuable
gi joe
anyway they refunded his whole thing so
like i ripped off the [ __ ] pokemon
cards dude
if floyd paid me i was gonna get the box
i was gonna get the box they assumed now
this is this is a stand-up guy stand up
guy he reimbursed me paid in full um he
he's a great guy he's a massive sports
card collector but him chasing his 2.7
million we're helping him you know we're
yeah we're trying we're trying to get
all the information we can because again
it's a whole thing it's people
suggesting i don't care
i don't care he's a great guy definitely
don't look into him
all right we're out of time
so anyway the point is is that he i
we're pretty sure he got me down by a
super trooper
which is why he got the gi joe cars
here is logan paul
who apparently is now living under a
bridge after
losing 3.5 million dollars and being
reimbursed
this is his thumbnail
i'm living under a bridge now i've lost
everything
is that the a joke cam
because he's a sucker looks like dan's
bridge i sold it to him that's right
yeah we got to stop dude we should try
to we should do a thing where we try to
scam logan paul into buying like the
fakest dumbest
pokemon cards watch there's a youtube
channel it's gonna be like how i scammed
logan paul right
[Laughter]
all right we're back
everyone's got their taco bell
you're already digging in you jump the
gun here hey i'm not i got nothing to
say
it's all bomb all right this is this is
mostly about love though right yeah yeah
yeah by the way so we're going to do
this we're going to test gloves appetite
for taco bell
and then we're going to be playing a
2022 prediction game
we're going to make predictions for this
what's gonna happen this year make
wagers on it
so we can check in throughout the year
and at the end of the year see
who was the most accurate the
nostradamus of the of the group
so love
show us what you got all right so i got
a silver pattern here so we got a
crunchy wrap supreme
burrito shupula
soft taco burrito supreme and some
cheese potatoes
now
why should i think it's got a chalupa
i think you should start with the
crunchwrap supreme okay yeah that's a
favorite of mine
it's a creative kind of crazy insane
dish i love that crunchwrap yeah i've
heard a lot of about it
all right
by the way is this cheesy potatoes a new
dish because this [ __ ] slaps like hard
no it's it's an older dish they brought
it back though there was a big
controversy in the taco bell community
over the last year because they
completely eliminated potatoes from
their menu
which are you a member of that community
dan oh absolutely lena was pissed
because that's all she eats from taco
bell really why would they do that i
don't understand the potatoes always
slapped and then like they removed the
mexican pizza which was mexican pizza is
gone
i i see people complaining a lot about
that
that was a sad day in our country i got
to agree that this is [ __ ] though
mexican pizza yeah i've never really
been a fan i love it
there you go a lot of people swear by it
apparently not
apparently nobody was ordering it i'm
tried and true always crunchwrap that is
always alright so love yep
should i just dig in yeah just take a
bite and see what you think
you have no idea what to expect in that
thing man nope
what is inside that it's like a taco and
a quesadilla inside a burrito and so
yeah
sour cream taco crunchy stuff
it's good though it's really good there
you go yeah
okay
is the diablo on the hotels
i don't know how i don't
i guess the diabolo's the hottest i feel
like the red one
gets me a little bit more but
yeah go for the dial that's fine um
the ingredients is tortilla beef
nacho cheese
a tostada shell lettuce
tomato
reduced fat sour cream thank god for
that oh yeah thank god
this is really good
one of the better things i've had in
your life
like fast food device yeah out of 10
give it a rating
uh a solid
nine i think wow
the crunchwrap sup the supreme ladies
and gentlemen
yep coming through big time all right
well let's move on to another one wait a
minute i just realized was there another
one of those it's on your desk i don't
know if it's actually on camera the
drink
oh
is that
best
he's got to try baja take it dude is
this it he has one oh you have one too
oh i'm sorry i've heard a lot about this
yes what is it just mountain dew
it's actually mountain dew and powerade
mixed don't give away this i think it's
better frozen i think the frozen one's
better well you know the taco bell
specifically it is you can probably get
a taco bell and um
it's probably my favorite soda hands
down
okay so love
i mean
yeah it's pretty good yeah sure that
next
this is a dorito
something
enchilada
uh sam can you like holy [ __ ] that was
crazy
this one this one has sheath on it so i
might not like it for that reason but
i'm going to try it though
the shredded cheese that's a strange
attribute not to like cheese
yeah for european
it's like can you explain what what he's
eating this [ __ ] is good though
i've actually never had it doritos locos
chalupa okay that's crazy dude it makes
you go insane
i've never had one i've actually got one
yeah this is good though what's that
movie called the chocolate fabric or
charlie and the chocolate factory yeah
what's the short people called in that
oh right i was mixing that up with
shumpaloo or whatever
yeah
chumbawamba
the taco you're not into
this one yeah i was i liked it dude
i like all this dude okay all right i
think because
i have never had any kind of tacos like
in fast food style
we don't have that in sweden but this
was very good okay yeah
ready
um
i mean i i'm gonna lower the first one a
little bit
eight and this one is also eight
did you lower your rating i lowered the
first one this is online that's it
yeah this one was better
the taco was better i
yeah i think so because the doritos was
really good that dorito dust baby okay
that dorito dust goes a long way okay up
next what do we got sam that's the
burrito supreme
oh that's a classic
that's a classic that's just a straight
burrito i've never had a burrito
except the one i had yesterday
but this is the first dry one
drum roll
[Music]
get in there like i do deep throat that
thing boy
big bite
oh yeah
we got oh yeah it's coming from love
this is really good too okay he loves it
he loves it that's gonna make it warm in
my heart dude taco bell makes this [ __ ]
they make this in a lab they like
yeah they there's some they put crack in
it it's like
msg
i'm just kidding
burning in their butthole
and taco bell is pretty infamous for
[ __ ] up digestive systems but
i don't know it it doesn't hit me but i
got uh for christmas chantal's mom got
me a gift card to chipotle
yeah and i i just i can't eat there
after ian's experience
i just i don't know what to do with the
thing though i'll take it you want the
kids experience i'll take it yeah i mean
i would take it yeah i mean
wait so it didn't make you sick it made
ian sick well now i'm fearful to eat
this [ __ ]
has it ever made you sick before it has
yeah
not as violent as ian but now i'm just
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i'll never i'll
never go there ever again it was like
really he got floored
no exaggeration it was really like weeks
it was the worst thing my stomach has
ever gone through in my life god what
could have been what what what kind of
meat did you eat
oh god i don't know i remember we showed
it on the show and it looked like
something zach would leave on a lawn
right right
[Music]
all
right
what's next
let's see let's slam this one
soft taco there's cheese in this one too
oh shredded cheese loves
she loves nemesis
i'm going to bring in the shoes out
yeah this one's pretty good too
it's all the same you'll learn yeah it's
all the same but this is why i have
potatoes in it
oh it does yeah okay interesting oh
all right there's one thing else
like not that special it's just like a
burrito with a potato yeah anything else
uh there
five out of ten
there's five out of ten
disappointing
cheese and potato
[Applause]
potato old potato
three out of ten
whoa
it's your potato with cheese and sour
cream bro yeah i don't like cheese
i'll slime all this though everything i
ate a little bit i'll eat it all so what
was your favorite item
um
honestly probably the dorito one
followed very closely by the
uh what was the big round thing he's got
trapped supreme dude yeah love love
really has no
gamer blood man of course the dorito one
is the one that got him yeah but if the
crunchy
the round thing if that one was newer
i'd probably like that one more
crunchwraps are something special yeah
they you know
they scientifically concocted like the
perfect little handheld it's not dude
that's the thing like
taco bell is not it's not
like it can't be considered actual food
it's like soylent or candy
yeah
i mean it's engineered literally just to
be
to [ __ ] with your brain to convince you
this is the best thing you've ever eaten
but there's no nutrients in it
you will die if you eat talk about
like exclusively yeah you'll die well
so love what uh what's the rank what do
you think taco bell
uh just because this is kind of a
novelty for me i never had tacos in my
way
[Music]
um
i'd say
eight out of ten total yeah
very nice
i'd love to hear that
so as someone who doesn't like cheese
what's your favorite food item
well
it's very specific i don't like when the
cheese is
taste too much but when it's melted i'm
fine with it like pizza and stuff
so what's your favorite food item
probably a good pizza kebab pizza wow
cause i like cheese favorite food pizza
yeah i know it's ironic
next thing we got to get love to try uh
ian
one of these
this is the burrito that's sent ian to
the hospital the burrito it's just a
[ __ ]
what an abomination man what was that
what like four months ago right
something like that i have not had
tripoli
yeah there was a mystery
there was a mystery bull so what
happened was
we ordered like a regular meal and then
they were like oh this was an extra
so this might have been tampered with
this is ecological
planting of you know inside the bag
and yeah
i didn't space it out over about two two
and a half days i don't think you're
chipotle's doesn't have a shelf life
yeah i mean that in the moment well
there's it's so much volume look at that
thing you had to throw that out dude i
feel like you had one opportunity
i think that i think that thing
turned into a petri dish after like
three hours i opened it and i was like
there's so much food i've i struck gold
here
i mean for days
and then you didn't have to eat for days
i can't dude i just can't
all right well fun times fun times
congratulations love
we'll have to make we should make a
cheerless uh tear maker for love with
all the food spots
yeah oh look at this
cam found the
the actual conversation when he was like
i'm on day six someone must have [ __ ] in
my food yeah i was trying to get him to
see a doctor because it was like
i really was actually dying did go to
the doctor
and they're and what did they say like
dude you just you just oh you just say
drink some water bro oh you ate chipotle
yeah okay well why didn't you say that
i was resisting it but then it hit like
day 14 and i was like i gotta go to the
doctor this is bad i might be dying
actually
yeah oh my god a little came out i'm
[ __ ] myself
actually i've already taken my pants off
um what was the wiping situation like
when you poop that much do you
like it becomes a delicate process right
ian are you don't you can't really fully
commit to
to a full and total cleanup after you
[ __ ] like your 10th time in a day right
well
you have to be
um
sort of
economic with the toilet paper usage so
it was so without getting into the gory
details
you know
i would go
and not leave the toilet
because i'm like it's going to hit me in
about
about three minutes
i don't want to use a double roll
so i'll just wait it out and then do one
wipe for two shits
i apologize yeah that no that makes
sense i mean you have to put it on like
the delicate setting and even the
delicate setting hits you wrong right
i'm surprised you could use toilet paper
i mean
that must be like sandpaper at that
point
all right i'm done thank you for
watching everyone oh we didn't ah we
didn't get to do it we didn't get to do
a lot of things i know
i know we spent so maybe on friday we
could do it with eli she'll enjoy that
all right
all right we'll be back on friday for
after dark live appreciate y'all thank
y'all so very special episode oh that's
the christmas app it is oh well [ __ ] we
now have time for anything
all right well whatever see you on
friday guys
love you god bless
[Music]